And now we are gonna play Celebrity.
And we have 30 seconds on the clock.
That's it?
30 seconds.
I can do it.
You have to guess really fast so you'll go first.
Alright.
You'll pick it up.
And then when I say start the clock and then I'll start giving you clues...
...and you have to guess who I'm telling you and then I'll be next.
Okay?
Yes.
Alright.
Are you ready?
Yes, go.
Oh, she's a beautiful actress.
She was in Catwoman.
Halle Berry.
Wow, that's fast.
Oh, he was a judge on American Idol but now he's on X Factor.
I worked with him.
Jennifer Lopez?
No, a guy.
He was on American Idol now he's on X Factor.
He's British, he's very very pompous and he judges everybody harshly.
Oh my god, Dakota Fanning!
No, it's a man.
No, you're not helping me, you're not helping me.
Next, next, next, next, next!
Oh, sexiest man alive.
Oh, Ocean's Eleven, Ocean's...
Jennifer Lopez!
Really, that's it?
That's what you give me?
That's what you gave me?
And you said Jennifer Lopez.
I'm sorry.
That's the clue that you give?
This is not how you play the game.
That's not how you play the game.
Somebody's a sore loser!
Alright.
It's not how I play it.
You're ready for my turn?
Yes, yes.
Alright.
I just thought you were good at it.
No, I'm actually really good at it.
I'm a little worried about you.
But it's your show so let's go.